It’s official: we have crossed a massive
milestone, with over 1 MILLION subscribers
now tuning in to Screenrant to stay up to
date on awesome movie trivia, easter eggs,
mistakes and more!
We couldn’t have done it without each and
every one of your help, so to show our gratitude,
we turned to you, our subscribers, to fill
us in on some of the coolest movie facts – and
you didn’t disappoint.
Here are 10 Amazing Movie Facts Brought To
You By Our Fans.
Home Alone – Buzz’s Girlfriend (from Crankii
Badger)
Kevin McCallister and his older brother Buzz
don't exactly get along, but the bully does
get burned by one of the movie's most lasting
jokes – well actually, it's his girlfriend
who takes most of the hit.
Since the joke about Buzz's girlfriend hinges
on the reveal that she is laughably ugly,
the director couldn't bring himself to subject
an innocent young actress to that straightforward
an insult.
Instead, he put a boy in a wig for the photo,
meaning the joke could work, but nobody's
feelings were hurt in the process.
Scream – The Birth of Ghost Face (from River
The Don)
Some horror icons are painstakingly created,
and others are just complete luck.
When Wes Craven decided to reinvent the modern
slasher movie with Scream, the actual script
never described what kind of mask the killer
was wearing.
It was only when scouting for locations that
a producer stumbled on the now-famous mask.
When Craven contacted the Fun World company
for the right to use their "peanut-eyed ghost"
mask in the movie, the company knew they had
the upper hand, and drove a hard bargain.
The crew then designed their own version of
the mask - different enough to not get sued
- and the company accepted the offer, and
the free publicity that came with it.
The "Ghostface" mask became iconic, but the
altered version still made the cut, visible
in the movie's opening sequence.
Dr. No – Itsy Bitsy Spider (from Aidan Butler)
Just because a movie's hero is a fearless
badass, that doesn't mean the actor playing
him had to be, too.
For plenty of James Bond fans, Sean Connery
will always be the best version of the suave,
womanizing secret agent.
But in his debut, the actor's fear of spiders
became a serious hurdle.
When the story planned for James to be threatened
by a deadly tarantula in his bed, Connery
couldn't let the spider actually crawl up
his arm, so the filmmakers cheated, putting
a pane of glass between the two.
It was easy to see the spider wasn't actually
on the actor, so in the end, a stuntman was
used.
It wasn't just Connery who had a thing about
spiders though - the stuntman said it was
the scariest scene he ever had to film.
Frozen – Reindeer Games (from Mari Roald
Meldal)
Sven the reindeer may be just a supporting
player in Disney's megahit, but he still got
plenty of laughs.
The animators took his character seriously,
examining real reindeer in their research
trip to Norway, the inspiration for the fictional
kingdom of Arandale.
They even had a small reindeer brought into
their office to capture its personality, but
soon realized it didn't really have one.
In the end, they relied on Pixar legend John
Lasseter's dog for inspiration, and the canine
habits are easy to see in the finished film.
The Godfather – Second Chance (from Emsal
Yaclin)
It's hard to imagine the story of the Corleone
family was every going to be any different
than the timeless masterpiece audiences eventually
got, but the movie almost featured a pair
of award winning icons before either had proved
their true talents.
Before James Caan had landed the role of Sonny
Corleone, the handsome son of Marlon Brando's
Don, actor Robert De Niro was pursuing the
part.
It's a shame to think both Pacino and De Niro
could have played brothers in one of cinema's
most revered dramas, but Francis Ford Coppola
made it up to De Niro by casting him in the
sequel, as a young Vito Corleone back home
in Sicily.
*That* role would land him an Oscar, the first
ever given for a role spoken mostly in a foreign
language.
Star Wars – Trusty Old Ford (from Caitlin
Mcewan)
As one of the most successful movie stars
in history, Harrison Ford has become synonymous
with not one, but TWO iconic movie franchises.
But his rise to fame started with Star Wars
- a role that he was never meant to even be
considered for.
After Ford won over George Lucas for a role
in American graffiti, the director failed
to see his star potential - but the producers
and casting agents around him didn't.
Lucas had no intention of casting Ford as
the smug smuggler Han Solo, but agreed to
let him read the part in auditions for the
other roles.
After countless hours, and other star actors
struggled to deliver, Lucas finally realized
Ford had the character all figured out.
He cast the actor, and the rest is history.
Die Hard With a Vengeance – McClane Says
(from Travis Allday)
Before Bruce Willis was jumping on jet fighters
or launching cars into helicopters, he was
solving riddles across New York city.
The third Die Hard movie ended with a memorable
bang, but did you know that wasn't actually
the original ending?
That's right, Die Hard With a Vengeance originally
had a darker, more badass ending that actually
sent John McClane off into the sunset on a
happy note.
After tracking Hans Gruber back to Germany,
John turns the tables, ambushing his enemy
with riddles of his own, playing Russian roulette
with a rocket launcher.
McClane - who had given up drinking and smoking
after almost being killed - comes out on top,
and leaving the expired Gruber to spend Christmas
with his family.
Star Wars – What’s in a Name? (from Gamer
of Darkness)
George Lucas tends to get all the credit for
dreaming up the Empire, Rebel Alliance, and
the droids of a galaxy far, far away – but
some of the planets owe their names to places
in our very own world.
Lucas hadn’t quite decided on a name for
Luke Skywalker’s planet when his first script
was completed, since so much of the action
takes place on other worlds.
But in the end, decided that the name of a
town in Tunisia was a perfect fit.
“Tataouine” or “Tatween” wasn’t
actually home to any of the movie’s locations,
but considering what an achievement it was
to make it out of the desert with the film
still on track, maybe the director thought
the name would be a good luck charm.
Harry Potter – It Wasn’t Butterbeer (from
The Sweggy Dinosaur)
There’s no pressure like that of a Hollywood
movie star, and for young actors, it’s only
more intense.
As the star of the Harry Potter series, actor
Daniel Radcliffe faced more pressure than
most people could grasp – and has since
admitted that he used alcohol to help him
cope.
The actor has since steered clear of drinking
entirely, and claims he never actually drank
on the set of the movies.
But coming into work drunk means Radcliffe
can point out scenes in the Harry Potter movies
where he is simply “dead behind the eyes.”
Since he refuses to say which movies or scenes,
fans can only guess.
Back to the Future – Method Acting (from
soccerjocks07)
Marty McFly is usually prepared for anything,
even if he’s dropping into a brand new decade
– or century.
But when Marty first winds up in 1885 in Back
to the Future Part 3, he needs Doc Brown to
save him from a guaranteed hanging at the
hands of Buford “Mad Dog” Tannen.
As it turns out, actor Michael j.
Fox needed some rescuing, too.
To film the scene, Fox had agreed to have
a real rope tied around his neck, and shown
how to keep himself safe by holding it slack.
When the procedure slipped his mind during
one take, the rope really did cut off his
air supply.
The crew and cast simply thought he had found
a way to play a strangled man even better…
until he passed out, at which point co-star
Christopher Lloyd severed the rope with a
single gunshot…
We hope.
Probably not though.
Those are the best behind-the-scenes details
that our fans supplied, but if you have more
to offer, keep them coming.
We couldn’t hit the million subscriber mark
without your time, so we hope you’ll subscribe,
if you haven’t already, and join us for
the next million to come!